sure might run to whiterun whiterun
Caucasian run I said live as access dude
tops excited that sees it as a chase it
down it just was water right here and
camp it's just not why is it so wet up
okay let's do that let's do this honey
bear bear I still life I was kind of
thing at Oh Liza god did I suppose it's
time I give him an answer prevent it
what do you make of all this it's all
free were to attack life run it count as
in all things Lord caution I oh just to
wait and see praying wait I'm Afra mind
with hiral f it's time to act you plan
to march on Windhelm I'm not a fool
provençal I mean it's time to challenge
all three to face me as a man and were
marked his Stormcloaks up to the gate
you'll do no such thing a dagger in the
back is all you could expect he was
rather straightforward with touring
touareg he simply walked up to the boy
and murdered him that boy was High King
of Skyrim I'm not the High King but
neither am i avoid if all freak wants to
challenge my rule in the old way let him
though I suspect you prefer to send it
stormcloaks to do it for him true he's
already proven his personal space now he
seeks to prove his army then might I
urge you to consider general Tullius
request I mean if you are bent on
offending y'all all free ulick is the
one who has offended but yes as a point
of it has made it clear in his mind to
review his claim it's aside with the
Empire
and what harm is there and letting a few
Legionnaires die in place of your own
men it seems cowardly once it's cowardly
then to accept the white [ __ ] away too
much this again that was different was i
given a chance to check to the terms of
the treaty that's known this i remain
yaros weren't asked we were told and we
had to like it the chests of gold didn't
hurt salmon this isn't about gold it's
time to decide floor wait let us see it
oh pretty serious oh he feels but so am
i killing batch so about this axe you
can return the facts to our friends the
esteemed er love Windhelm has my answer
make sure he gets it and bring me my
past I'm to the start we won't wait I no
no in an ally batch mmm a fe NM may yet
have lipstick on your pants
okay okay get us where I can not much of
a strategy what ultra key to my concert
hall today i'll talk about this i'm not
sure what when I was wrong about him and
imperial you're right doll mark again
I'm in no mood to joke give the Lord my
lord and wipe Rodney's your wife on is
only a means to an end I've toured are
we ready oh frick whenever you are
there's any man ever ready to give the
order that will mean the death of men
yeah no but neither is every man able to
give that order when he must but you
want that manual trick you've been that
man before and you'll be him again and
these men and women they call themselves
stormcloaks because they believe in you
therefore sensor errors and omissions
stop if sons of [ __ ] Skyrim has to
offer and they want it they want this as
much as you do perhaps they wanted more
you're certain we're ready white runs
army will no doubt the bolster with
Legionnaires and those walls around
white runner old but they still fat and
chilly why are you all ready and I might
be old myself but I'll kick those damn
walls down with my bare feet if you
would only ask me to do it ha and I'm
sure you could do it too all right this
is it that's a match
send the word a new day is dawning and
the Sun rises over white run I and the
sons of Skyrim will greet that dawn
teeth and sword slashing so it begins
make haste to our camp in white one I
want you on the front line I have a
feeling about you your place is on that
battlefield I fight well or die well
Carlos be with you all right catch